[Music]
alpha code is a system by deepmind that
does automated competitive programming
you're able to give this system a lead
code style problem in natural language
and it will come up with code by itself
that solves the problem it does this by
using a combination of language modeling
sampling filtering and clustering before
it finally decides on the solutions that
it's going to try out to submit to the
server what is mind-blowing is that this
system was able to perform in human
competitions and be about as good as the
average programmer in these competitions
which is crazy because previous systems
were nowhere near human level so here's
how it goes this video right here is a
comprehensive paper review where i will
go through the paper with you and
explain to you the most important parts
of the paper what's in there and what i
think is good and what i think is bad
after this video you'll have a good
understanding of the paper and of how
the system works and what its potential
weaknesses are however in the next video
released tomorrow i will interview the
authors of alpha code which is a huge
privilege and i'll be able to ask them
anything i want and they will have seen
my paper review and they'll be directly
able to respond to any criticism that
i've raised there to any questions that
i had and to whatever i did wrong in my
paper review on top of that you're able
to get a behind-the-scenes look into
their work even at places like deepmind
things go wrong things don't work out
they've had results that they thought
were too good to be true
and they turned out not to be true and
many more things on top of that we talk
about how the project came to be and
also how they've dealt with media
reception because this paper has made
big waves so i absolutely invite you to
watch both this video and the interview
part because they're very much
complementary let me know how i can
improve these videos for you if you like
leave a like tell someone to subscribe
and i'll see you around bye
hello there today we're going to look at
competition level code generation with
alpha code this is by researchers of
deepmind and presents a novel system
that can take part in competitive
programming challenges these are
challenges where you as a user you'd
register and then you'd be given lead
code style problems to solve and these
aren't easy problems these aren't just
solving some or writing down some sql
statement these are legitimate difficult
programming challenges where you need to
think of algorithms and solutions to
problems and so on so
having a system that can actually take
part and
compete against humans is very
remarkable they've submitted this system
to 10 of these challenges and as you can
see the orange lines here is alpha codes
relation to other humans they perform
about as as well as a median human would
like in like an average
middle of the road competitive
programmer if you will
so this is pretty remarkable especially
since the baseline system so far had
been
no sort of in the third or fourth
percentile uh not very good
so this represents a significant boost
and today we're going to find out how
they did it but first
here is what such a problem might look
like so this is
one problem this is one data point in
this in this data set or
one such challenge that you have to
solve you can see it starts with a
description so the title is backspace it
starts with a description you're given
two strings s and t both consisting of
lowercase english letters yada yada yada
what you should note right here is that
the description is in natural language
it's made for humans and therefore it's
just natural that it is a natural
language there is no other form there's
no machine readable form right here this
is it
this is what the algorithm alpha code
sees and gets as an input
there's also a description of the input
again in natural language there's
description of the output and there is
also this part right here this is an
important part
it consists of a bunch of example inputs
and outputs so here is an example input
for example there are four problems in
this problem set all of this will be
described
in the input section so the input
section here says the first line is a
single integer the number of test cases
and so on so that's the four um then we
have this is a problem so this is s and
this is t of the first problem the goal
is to type s and strategic strategically
type the backspace button instead of the
letter at s
to go from s to t
so in this case
we start with s so the first letter is a
but we choose to type the backspace
button which would not type a and would
delete what we have but we have nothing
so
uh yeah then we would type b
sorry about that and we would type b
then we would type a then we would type
b and instead of the last a we again
type the backspace button which would
delete the letter before it and we'd end
up with b a therefore we got from s to t
and therefore we output the let the word
yes okay so we are
tasked with writing an algorithm that
automatically determines whether it's
possible to go from s to t
in any of these test cases
and output the corresponding answer this
is challenging by itself but you only
get the problem right if you can do it
for all the test cases
and the way these problems are evaluated
is that on the on the test server they
have a whole bunch more of these test
cases
and including checking all the corner
cases like very long inputs no input at
all uh only inputs containing the letter
a
if for some reason you expected a b to
be there and
so they test all the edge cases and you
need to be correct in all of them in
order to get the points this
is extremely challenging even for a
human the output that
you're supposed to give is an algorithm
like this you can see it's not an easy
thing it's not just
a snippet it's a full-blown algorithm it
contains inputs so you read
you read the inputs even that to program
an algorithm to come up with that piece
of code is already challenging by itself
to firstly read that first
let the first line and then read as many
inputs then you need to build lists and
reverse lists then you go into a while
loop where you pop off things of list
depending on comparisons and in the end
you output
the correct thing depending on whether
that list is zero
or empty or not empty so as you can see
this is this is a challenging um a
challenging task and this is just one
data point the next data point isn't
going to be another variant on two
strings and and typing the backspace
button the next data point is going to
be a completely different problem right
like uh
searching for shortest paths and some
graph or
uh something with
denominators of
numbers or numerators or
or something like this right it is
it is very diverse set of problems and
very challenging even for humans and the
fact that an algorithm can tackle it is
very remarkable so how do they do it um
that's that's our question today if you
guessed that it has something to do with
large language models um then and
transformers and and so on then
yes you know kudos
you got it uh but there is a lot more to
it and this is really an engineering
effort um and and i think we should
appreciate just you know how far you can
push a system to get continuous
improvements
what they do first though is they
collect a data set
they do train on a open source code from
github
that is the pre-training data set this
is very similar to openai's codex model
so openai's codex model is trained on
code from github and it can simply do
next token prediction on code
and i have to say i've tried codex and
i'm pretty happy with its suggestions is
very good
but it can give me like
longer snippets than an autocomplete uh
but it cannot like solve any kind of
problems like this it can just continue
code
in any case they collect this
pre-training data set they have whatever
700 gigabytes of code that they train on
and
they
run their regular
language modeling objective on that
piece of code
then they fine tune on an appropriate
data set of code contests
so this is a mixture data set that they
scrape from multiple websites for
example code forces description to code
codenet these are these are
papers previous papers or uh competition
settings that they have
collected these
data sets from and the data sets again
this here is one data point right this
is a problem description and usually
these um these uh
data sets they contain one or multiple
solutions not all of them might be
correct but they contain about an order
of magnitude more solutions than they
contain uh
text or just problem descriptions
so first they collect a data set
and then they train on that data set so
that could be the story right here but
it is not
the entire pipeline is a bit more
complicated
you can see first there's github we
collect pre-training data we do
pre-training
then fine-tuning on
pairs of problems and solutions of these
code contests data set this is as i said
a collection of various data sets that
contain these
that contain these code
uh challenge
type of problems lead code style
problems and they do fine tuning by the
way their model is a transformer model
you could guess it they do have a
special they have an encoder decoder
model so you have some sort of an
encoder and they choose to make the
encoder shallow and the decoder
the decoder deep and there are specific
reasons for that which we'll get to in a
second but the encoder mainly handles
the this description which is
so the description is natural language
mostly contains you know some some code
snippets and so on um
however
it contains mostly the description
that's the encoder uh the benefit of
using an encoder decoder architecture
over a decoder only is that you do get
bi-directionality in the encoder and as
they do here you can make them different
sizes which means that you can shrink
the encoder which makes you sample able
to sample faster and sampling is going
to be very important for this system
right here in just a second and then the
decoder will be a auto aggressive
decoder where they uh they just well int
j equals five
yada yada so this is this is actually
going to produce the code token by token
in sort of a language modeling way their
objective is is uh they have a masked
language model objective at the encoder
and then the decoder obviously there's a
cross attention right here there's
there's self attention in the encoder
their self attention causal self
attention in the decoder and then there
is cross attention from the decoder to
the encoder and they have a uh
a language modeling objective in the
decoder
they do say uh it's quite important to
have the masked language modeling loss
additionally in the encoder because it
apparently makes the encoder understand
uh the
the stuff in inside of it the stuff that
it's fed a lot better i'm just gonna
believe them right here
so now that we have this model uh we can
we can fine-tune it on these data sets
right we can feed a description right
here and we can feed one of the
solutions
and um
that could already be it however that's
not it it turns out that most of the
time this doesn't actually solve the
problem so you feed in a description and
you sample the solution it it is not it
does not go well so what do they do
well there are two ways
the first way is you try to make your
model a lot better at like thinking and
coming up with solutions and reasoning
abstractly and so on but
um that doesn't sound very deep learning
and transformer-like so what do we do is
we just do
scale sampling
that essentially means you have a
problem you get a new problem you feed
this into your decoder right here
and then you just sample like a bunch
of solutions from your decoder sorry i
just said decode over here you put this
into the encoder you let the decoder run
and you generate a ginormous a ginormous
amount of outputs so you can do this
with language models you can sample
according to some temperature you can do
some other stuff and you do nuclear
sampling and whatnot but you can
generate diverse outputs from the
decoder
and
they do they sample thousands up to a
million different outputs from the
decoder
so now they have this large set of
potential solutions
what do they do with it this is very
important they do filter and they
cluster so first the filtering happens
and it might not surprise you but the
filtering happens on these example
inputs that we saw right here so with
every problem you get a tiny amount of
example inputs and corresponding example
outputs they simply let all of the
programs they generate run on these
example inputs and the ones that don't
crash
they evaluate whether they do get the
example outputs and if they do get the
example outputs correctly they keep them
around otherwise they discard them this
is obviously vastly different from how
humans solve these things humans don't
just generate giant amounts of solutions
and then
let them run on this tiny amount of
example problems but this eliminates as
they say it eliminates over 99
of these
sample things so you end up with a
slice right here of this data that
you've generated
by simply evaluating on
by simply evaluating on these
example cases that you had so it's quite
important that these are there for the
system to work
i wonder if if like we could replace
this because we we have this approach as
well in for example dali where a lot of
stuff is generated and then clip is used
to re-rank i wonder if something like
this could be done here
but they have several helper models in
here
in order to in order to to help the
system during during training so i don't
know if another helper model um might be
might be
even appropriate
so this leaves them with a tiny amount
of solutions which could still be a lot
right 99 out of a million is still a lot
of solutions and they keep themselves to
just submitting 10 of them so as a human
sometimes these code platforms they have
actually a limit on how many things you
can try to submit
and
10 is like a reasonable limit it gives
you a little bit of of as a human a
little bit of
you're not anxious to submit a solution
uh if you think it's the correct one
sorry but you also you can submit a few
times but not too often like you can't
brute force the test set that's on the
server
so they need to get down from these
still large amount of solutions to 10
solutions and that's where this
clustering comes in
so the goal is to end up with this small
select set of candidates to to execute
and evaluate and what do they do with
the clustering this is where one of
these helper models gets in so all of
these things right here they are
programs they're programs that could
take
inputs and outputs and there are many
many of them
okay
what we want to do is we want to cluster
them a lot of these programs are going
to be different in the tokens that they
use like in the exact code but they're
going to be essentially the equivalent
program to each other like they're going
to be the same
program isomorphic to each other however
graph isomorphism like let's say we
parse them in a syntax tree and check
graph isomorphism that's i i do believe
that's like a really hard problem i
might be mistaken but i think that's
used in cryptography to show like a
really hard problem so it's not really
graph isomorphism on the syntax tree it
might not even get
all the isomorphic programs so what do
we do our plan is going to be we want to
group these programs into the same one
so maybe these three here are actually
the same and this one here is actually
the same so
we'd like to figure that out how do we
do it we just feed like a whole bunch of
inputs like we just
generate a whole bunch of inputs
to the programs
and this is we train a little model that
can take descriptions um like problem
descriptions and generate new input
output pairs not even input output pairs
just inputs
so we take a problem and we take these
example inputs and it can generate new
ones now we don't care what the output
is what we do care is we just feed all
of them to all of the models like
all of them go to all of the models and
we just observe the outputs and we say
well
whenever two programs have the same
outputs on all of these test cases that
we came up with they're the same program
we don't we don't again we don't know
the solutions to these inputs because we
made them up
but
we can assume that if two programs
output the same thing for all kinds of
inputs that they're essentially the
equivalent program note that we can't
just input random garbage right here
because the programs might differ with
respect to how they handle edge cases
and so on so it is good to have an
informed model be the one that's in
putting things into these models but
this lets us figure out groups let's say
okay all of these models responded the
same to all of these inputs that we gave
them so we'll just consider that the
same program and we'll just submit one
of them um as the one of the ten then we
go to the next bucket submit one of
those and so on we start with the
largest bucket and then we progressively
go to the smaller buckets and if we
still have some some budget left we go
to the largest bucket again and sample a
different one
but that's essentially how we group
programs and that's how they get it down
to fairly small set of candidates why do
they start with the largest bucket their
reasoning is that um
is that
wrong pro there are many ways that wrong
programs can be wrong
so uh
selecting the largest bucket um i don't
know we'll we'll have to read what
they're saying but essentially they say
there are many ways to introduce bugs
and um
there
and and therefore they expect the wrong
programs to be in smaller but distinct
buckets
and that's the system that is how they
solve the programming competition this
might not be as flashy as you know you
imagined but it it's still very very
impressive
this strategy of generating a whole
bunch of things and then selecting i
think has been
popularized more and more in recent
times
as i said for example with systems like
dali we've seen
that generative models
can be used to generate very diverse
sets of outputs if they are
post-processed correctly we can end up
with something that the generative model
by itself could not necessarily have
done
right this is the base of the system now
as i already said there are a lot of of
engineering things right here most
notably um
if you are going to sample such a large
amount of things in order to answer a
single data point
sampling needs to be very very fast and
a lot of their engineering choices are
in order to make sampling fast for
example as you can see their encoders
are consistently
smaller than their decoders they have
shallow encoders but deep decoders
precisely for that reason making the
encoder more shallow saves on parameters
saves on forward propagation makes
sampling a lot faster hey this is yanik
from the future just a small correction
right here i claimed that the
shallowness of the encoder would help
with the sampling speed which is not
entirely true in fact in sampling the
decoder is the bottleneck because you
can reuse the encoders encoding over and
over again as you auto regressively
sample
so the decoder being small would help
the sampling speed but they figured uh
the the decoder really needs to be deep
in order to keep keep up performance
uh the encoder being shallow helps
really during training because during
training i don't do anything
autoregressively and therefore any part
being smaller really helps the speed
during training so just small correction
back to the video
they also use the uh shared the user an
ex a
they use a
system like a transformer variant that
shares all of the values and keys across
the heads
as you can see right here for example
here we have six query heads but all of
the keys and values are shared among
those heads this again saves computation
and makes sampling a lot faster
so that is that is
how they make
this sampling even tractable right
because
uh these choices influence how many
solutions you can generate at once and
uh yeah that's
they already say it's a massive
it's a massive effort to generate these
solutions at runtime although i wonder
like what what does that mean like a
couple of seconds or or what because
humans are time limited in these
challenges and that's one of the major
obstacles is that um
you're under time pressure as a human so
i wonder how that kind of plays into
into codex right here what do they mean
by you know it's a lot of effort to
generate these things and how much time
does it actually take in any case
they
they have a lots of intricacies right
here for example they they add
additional meta information to the
problem description so they feed this
stuff here into the problem description
as well for example what the language is
whether or not whether or not
the solution that the training so in the
training data they know whether a
solution is correct or not
um whether or not it's the correct
solution
and uh
for ex and also tags
tags might help you for example this is
dynamic programming
that implementation i don't know what
implementation tag is oh maybe you must
implement an actual algorithm instead of
just
solving a decidability problem a rating
to indicate how hard the problem is
this
these things are not known at test time
however they've discovered that if they
include them at training time
it helps a lot and obviously at test
time you cannot just always input
correct solution right that's how you
can let your model train on even
incorrect solutions
and still not have the incorrect
solutions during training contaminate
like the model trying to produce correct
solutions so there's potentially
something that the model can learn from
the incorrect solutions yeah at test
time you just always put correct
solution it's a bit pretentious but um
you know
it is what it is and they also discover
that uh by varying the tags right here
obviously they don't have the tags
because they could give a hint in how
you solve the problem um but they can
just put like random tags there and that
would even increase the diversity of the
things they sample and that's ultimately
what they go for right here a very
diverse set of potential solutions that
they can then filter down and cluster
down so i thought this was this was
quite smart um to include sort of
data that you only know at training time
and then use that in a creative manner
it's sort of like prompt engineering in
gpt3
but in an in an automated and planned
fashion right
so they go through a lot of thing right
i don't have no time to go through all
of this but i highly encourage you to
read all of it they have various
technique techniques right here uh they
do they do tempering they do value
conditioning that also helps value
prediction that also helps this is a
little bit like reinforcement learning
where you add additional proxy losses in
order to make the model understand the
problem space better or maybe learn more
relevant features um they they do
re-weighting of the gradient with this
technique called gold and
yeah as as i can just
if you're if you're interested this is
very
very detailed paper and i found it also
quite easy and straightforward to read
and i i will hope you have the same
experience
as we said they get to the filtering and
they say filtering removes approximately
99 of model samples although the exact
amount depends on the problem and the
model
and filtering can still leave
thousands or tens of thousands of
candidate samples for many problems
so
that's why they they filter them they
filter them down and after filtering
they use this this clustering algorithm
which i've already described so i won't
do that again right here
but now we go into
the results already and the results are
themselves quite interesting
uh not only because of the performance
of the model which is pretty good um at
least for some of the models so they
train different models right here in
different sizes but also because they do
very detailed investigations into what
the individual
contributions uh that they introduced
brought
so as you can see right here for example
this this metric right here by the way
10 at 10k it means they submit 10
examples at the end so this is after the
whole clustering and so on um and they
generate 10 000 candidate solutions so
at that size if they consult their 9
billion parameter model you can see they
get a a pass rate or a solve rate of
22.6
of the validation set examples that they
have
if they use their 41 billion parameter
model
that increases and if they additionally
use clustering instead of just randomly
sampling 10 examples from the filtered
data set they
get 26.2 percent you can see right here
both size and the additional features
that they build in get them a large gain
and this is consistent across all the
the sizes and so on and what you can
also see is that sampling more
distinctly helps for example if you go
to a hundred thousand or a million
samples even though
you only submit ten of them at the end
still
if you sample more all of the models
automatically get better as you can see
um
yeah so that is i think that that is a a
good a good lesson and an indication of
what could be done more in the future to
augment our generative models with
post-processing
so the paper
is quite long it's actually copied again
right here
we'll just jump more into the results
section because there are some other
very interesting things
for example
if you look at how the models compare in
their size there's clearly as we already
saw there is an advantage to being
larger which you can see right here 300
million parameters performing okay 41
billion parameters performing a lot
better you can see at this point right
here
the
small model solves not even 20 percent
of problems the large model solves more
than half of the problems more than the
small small model you can also see that
when they are unrestricted so unlimited
attempts instead of just 10 attempts so
unlimited attempts we don't need
clustering we don't need filtering we
could filter right because like there's
zero chance that a problem that doesn't
pass the test inputs will actually pass
the uh the server inputs
but no clustering no selecting no sub
selecting you can see that um
the models they just get better as you
sample more which
makes sense right this must be a
monotonous function as you sample more
your chance of getting some of some
solution being correct is like gets more
and more but there are so many programs
like the space of possible programs is
so huge even the space of possible
programs in these data sets is like or
that that would confer to these is so
large this is really astonishing to me
to see that um there is really this this
improvement
it's log linear yes this is a log skill
but still it it seems um
it seems crazy that you can actually get
a better performance by just you know
sampling more searching through this
space more according to the language
models also notable is that the large
models have a bigger slope than the
small models i've i've overdone it a bit
with my drawing right here but i hope
you can still see it so the large models
have better
scaling properties with respect to
sampling from them
which is also interesting and will be
another i think addition to
to the common knowledge of how these mod
like of the scaling laws of these models
so whether you filter them down to 10
problems which at some point gets you
diminishing returns or whether you not
don't fill to them in which case i don't
see any diminishing returns right here
it just kind of speeds up
again these are log scales on the bottom
so it seems very to concur very well
with the scaling laws we have in that in
order to get like a linear improvement
in performance you need an exponential
improvement in
data compute or in this case
samples
the next thing they uh
so they they look at they look at
various things right here like how long
they train obviously with uh more
training compute again our solve rate
goes up again this seems to be a log
linear relationship which is uh also
very interesting and
also the
the uh solve rate goes up with more
sampling compute which is kind of the
same plot as above but here it's
measured in terms of compute and not
necessarily in terms of
of number of samples obviously the
larger models they do
take a longer time to forward propagate
and therefore use more compute but
interestingly because of their scaling
property you can see that at the
beginning because they take longer
they need more compute to reach the same
pass rate or solve rate however
as you go up with the compute because of
their slope being
being higher right here they eventually
will surpass the other models and even
seen from a compute perspective it will
be cheaper to use the larger model
than to use the small models for the
same performance
yeah here
they
investigate their decisions with respect
to how fast they can sample you see
right here the alpha code model can
sample at 4.74
samples
per tpu second
if they were to use a decoder only model
they would be a lot slower because now
obviously the decoder has a
bigger length which means the attention
matrix has a bigger
um a bigger size i guess they also
allocate more blocks to the decoder so
that the parameters are approximately
equal
which then means all in all means that
this
architecture is in total slower because
as more connections has more blocks
then
they also they test with the regular
transformer like standard multi-head
attention and and that's just kind of
abysmal
um so this is due to the fact that they
use this shared query attention right
here in their architecture and um yeah
yes okay this is the same the same
encoder decoder split but they use a
they use a
a different
they don't use the shared query
so that is speed now what i also find
interesting is the pre-training data set
i'm sorry we'll go we go through a lot
of results right here but they're all
very interesting um so the pre-training
data set used also influences the
performance at the end but as you can
see if they restrict themselves to
github but python only instead of github
all languages and all languages mean
something like python and c plus and
julia and and things like this um but
it's it's still programming languages so
if they use python only their solve rate
drops dramatically however if they use
massive text and massive text does
contain some github data um
but it's also a natural language data
set it doesn't drop as much i just i
think that's quite interesting like why
might that be i don't know
um
yeah here they
they
list up all the advancements and don't
want to go through them but you can just
see
how
just how engineering plays in here it's
not just i have an idea and i build the
model no no it's um you know if i just
build the model i get 10.4 percent right
here but then i add um multi i add the
encoder loss of the mask language model
i add the tempering i add the
the tags and ratings so the
the little snippet they put in front
that they randomize at test time right
um i add the value predictions i add
this this weighting of the gradient i
add the clustering you can see that with
everything they add they get improvement
after improvement so i guess what the
lesson here is that uh there might
always be a way to sort of push your
system even further
by
just
adding something something smart or
alternatively just scaling by a
factor of 10 but you know
that i guess that's the sad story of
deep learning right um because these
these things they kind of give you a
constant improvement right you can see
that across all of the things right here
for example the first the mass language
modeling gives you maybe not here but
maybe not here but here like a two
percent this is about two percent this
is about two percent improvement um
and
you know some of these things they scale
with size but some of them also kind of
give you a constant improvement and
the the the you can you can always get
the same improvement by just scaling up
models right in fact you look at you
have to get all of these improvements
right here uh or you just scale up the
model by a factor of 10 and you get like
also an improvement
sad story of deep learning
um
yeah this right here
is a comparison of um
this is a comparison of the filtering
and clustering algorithms so if they
just do no filtering they just select 10
outputs at random obviously their solve
rate is just a zero because they
generate like most of the generated
samples they are just garbage they don't
well they don't solve the problem so if
they now filter that already gives the
biggest boost right that eliminates the
99
that fail on the test inputs and
therefore um
that is that is pretty pretty
significant improvement if they also add
clustering then as you can see
especially at the larger
sample budgets uh the clustering helps a
lot and the blue line here is a
theoretical upper bound so the blue line
is where they just submit every single
thing that they sample and see how much
that would solve so this is theoretical
upper bound if they could always sample
and select not sample the correct but if
they could always select the correct
things from the things they sampled
you can see that there is still a big
gap so even though they do this whole
clustering thing
they seem to be still unable in
let's say about 10
or
so about 10 percentage points or so of
solutions to actually come up with the
to select the correct solution among all
of their candidates
which is surprising right um maybe not
maybe not i mean
yeah
i don't know
they do test against bass lines and i
guess the only thing to be said is that
the bass lines they
uh sometimes succeed on easy problems
you can see right here that in the
introductory in the introductory
problems something like codex
doesn't perform too poorly
however uh as soon as you go to like
competition level problems and this is a
this is a different data set right here
in different methodologies in order to
make the models comparable and their
alpha code
just shines
quite outshines its competitors quite a
bit and this is the one one billion
model uh this is not even the larger
model
they do compare
whether or not the model just copies
over code and they have a lot of ways to
investigate that and they find that
largely no it doesn't copy more code
than humans copy uh therefore so also
humans in these competitions they they
have some algorithm in mind that they've
seen somewhere they just write it down
again or they even actively copy from
other solutions uh they do investigate
quantitatively and qualitatively that
right here and they find that the model
largely does not um
that is it does not
um
copy over entire solutions from
somewhere else like it doesn't just try
out all the things that it has seen so
far
there are other tricks right here sorry
there are also
ablations which i this video is already
too long so i don't want to necessarily
go into it into all of the things
one interesting thing is that
they report that their validation loss
after a very short time increases so you
can see right here the validation loss
drops and after a while it increases
again this would indicate overfitting
usually and you can see that for the
rest of the run the validation loss
increases however their real metric the
true metric the the solve rate um
actually increases too throughout you
can see right here the solve rate
increasing throughout the run there's
diminishing returns but it does continue
to increase which
means that the validation loss is not
necessarily a good metric
they do have an explanation for this
namely that
these coding models
there's not one correct solution not
even in the data set right the data set
contains many instances of
problem a and then solution one solution
two solution three solution four so if
the model learned to produce solution
one for problem a which is a correct
solution but the current data point um
wants the model to produce solution two
right
because you're doing language modeling
you need to select one that you train on
then that would technically you know be
wrong and therefore if you measure this
on the validation set you might you
might
you know you might actually get worse
yet still
you might actually increase in your
ability to solve the actual problems
this leads me to believe a little bit
that you know is the training loss even
appropriate for this for this thing i
mean it's fine you know the validation
loss goes up i can understand why and
why that might not be necessarily a
problem but is does that kind of mean
that the training loss itself
should be rethought
and that we should have a better
training loss for these types of models
where multiple continuations multiple
solutions exist in the data set to the
same
prefix
i don't know
that is one of many questions that i
have right here as i said they have lots
of other stuff they augment the data set
with some some fuzzing procedure um they
they do
lots lots of different things and
investigations
the paper also has a long appendix if
you're if you're into that you can see a
lot more stuff a lot more analysis but i
think i'm going to leave it here and
jump over to the interview
thanks so much and i hope you enjoy that
as well
[Music]
you